should we yeah yeah i think it's
that's good well
um thanks everyone um we're delighted to
have ashley edwards here today as our um
invited speaker
um ashley i got her phd from georgia
tech working with
charles isabel she's done a lot of work
in reinforcement learning she's been at
um
uber ai labs and will be joining
deepmind um in about a week it sounds
like which is an exciting new adventure
she's also given a number of invited
talks um including
an invited talk at the women in machine
learning um workshop at
uh nurbs last year um and we're really
excited to hear what she
is going to tell us today about learning
to act from observations
yeah thank you so much for the
introduction and thank you again
for inviting me to give this talk i'm
really excited to be here
um and yeah thank everyone thank you for
um for joining me during this talk
so i'm excited to be talking about my
recent works on how we can train agents
to act from observation
um so as humans we're very lucky to be
able to learn from
many different sources of information so
for example we can learn to dance by
playing video games or to cook by
watching youtube videos
or make origami diagrams um by studying
different figures
and so i think one interesting question
that we should ask ourselves
is how can we allow agents to learn from
sources such like
such as this because if we can figure
this out then it might allow us to
train agents using the vast amount of
information that's available
to us to learn from so one thing we can
try to consider is just
what are some of the properties that
allow us to learn from
these different sorts of tasks
so firstly we're often able to learn
across domains
so for solving some sort of task it
often takes place um
when we're looking at how to accomplish
it um in a different environment than
our own
and we have to solve some sort of
correspondence problem to figure out how
to solve the task
next we're capable of imitating from
observation
and so often when we're watching
somebody perform some task
we need to infer which actions that they
took in order to figure out how to solve
a task ourselves
um and finally although this isn't
necessarily modeled in these different
examples i've shown here
um we're often capable of learning from
imperfect
observations and so if we watch somebody
perform some tasks and we want to do it
ourselves
um maybe that person didn't perform it
optimally but we're often able to
improve upon
what we've observed in order to perform
a task
better so during this talk i'm going to
focus on these latter two points of how
agents can imitate from observation as
well as learn from observations and
perform better than
um it's demonstrators although i do
think cross-domain learning is
definitely important as well and i've
done some work in this area
um as well and so during this talk is
just a very simple um outline i thought
it'd be useful for you to know
um so i'm going to first start off
talking about just some of the
background behind um some of the work
that i've been done
then i'll describe some of my work on
imitation from observation
and then learning from observation and
then i'll just talk about
briefly uh about some of the future
directions
for imitation and learning from
observation
okay so uh throughout this series and
um you know your reinforcement learning
careers you've probably seen a diagram
that looks something
similar to this uh where you have an
agent that's taking actions
and it's interacting with its
environments and it's receiving rewards
um
and it's what it's trying to do is it's
trying to learn a policy that's going to
say
in a given state which action should i
take and what you want to learn is
what actions will allow me to maximize
my long-term
future discounted return often
represented through
these q values here um and a lot of the
magic behind reinforcement learning
comes from the reward signal so if you
can you know if you can come up with a
good reward function
then reinforce the learning agents are
often able to solve a lot of really
interesting
problems um but i think some of the
magic sort of disappears when you when
you actually have to go off and
make these reinforcement learning agents
yourself um
so uh anka talked a bit about this
during um her talk on monday but
um so reward signals can often be very
very difficult to specify
um humans often don't know how to
specify reward functions and even if you
come up with something that seems
reasonable
the agent can learn to exploit it so
that's one problem
another problem problem is that reward
signals are often sparse
so even if you specify it correctly it
might take a really long time for the
agent to
figure out how to solve the test just
from this far signal
um or it might not ever be able to
figure out on its own
so one solution to this sort of problem
is
that we can have a human in the loop
that's going to show
the agent how to accomplish the task and
so
what they're going to say is in this
state this is the action that you should
take in
so um basically we want this person to
give some demonstrations for how to
solve the task
and so this sort of learning setup is
often known as
imitation learning uh where you're going
to be given demonstrations
represented as a sequence of states and
actions and again these actions are
going
going to be coming from some
demonstrator
often somebody that knows how to solve
the task and
given this data we're going to try to
learn something so we can learn for
example a policy
and i guess the simplest or one of the
simplest
ways to learn a policy is through
something called behavioral coding
that's going to say in this state just
predict which action
um the demonstrator took using something
like supervised learning
we can also learn uh reward functions
from
from demonstrations as well as values uh
but if we want to have a sort of world
where you know we just have agents going
off and maybe watching videos or
observing other agents maybe animals
other robots
then we're often not going to have
access to these actions
um and so what i want to just consider
is how can
we train agents to learn only from a
sequence of states
coming from something like a video um
where again we're not going to have
access to
actions and so that approach is
typically known as imitation from
observation
and there are a couple of different
approaches for doing imitation from
observation
one is to learn a reward function and
then use that reward function
for training reinforcement learning
agents another is to learn a dynamics
model
and what i mean is that you can place
the agent within its environments
learn something about how um the
dynamics work so you might say like in
this state
if i ended up in this state this is the
action that um
that was taken and then you can use
those sort of dynamics models to predict
which actions the
demonstrator took from your sequence of
states
um one problem with these kinds of
approaches
though is that they require a lot of
environment interactions so you can
imagine
doing reinforcement learning in the
environment learning these dynamics
models um
might require a lot of environment
interactions and
and so what i want to consider in the
rest of this talk and um so i'm going to
discuss
different techniques for this is how we
can actually
try to learn as much as we can offline
from the observations alone
before the agent ever takes any steps
within the environment
okay so imagine your friend is playing a
video game that you've never
seen before uh so by watching them play
we can often get an idea of how the game
works
um so in this example we see that um you
know there's these different enemies
that we need to avoid
we need to jump over these different
obstacles
and there's a coin at the end of a
platform that we need to reach
um and so once we watch our friend play
you know after we pick up the controller
even though we've never played the game
before um we can often just play really
quickly once we've figured out the
actual controls
and that's because we figured out the
sort of um let's call it a policy
that our friend is following and we've
we've figured out what the
um the point of the game is just by
watching our friend
play and so that was the idea behind
our recent work imitating latent
policies from observation or ill-po
where we're going to be given a sequence
of observations
and again remember we don't have access
to actions in this scenario
and from the sequence of observations
we're going to try to learn
a latent policy um so
what i mean is this is going to be like
the sort of watch step where we're going
to watch
these observations and figure out how
the task should be solved
even though we don't know the names of
the actions um
then once we learn that latent policy
we're going to place the agent into the
environment
um just so that it can take a few steps
so that it can try to align um
it's its notion of these latent policies
or latent actions
to the real actions that it can take in
the world
okay um so let's say that we've sampled
the state from our demonstration set
from that state we might observe two
different kinds of transitions
one would be something that looked like
moving to the right or something that
looked like jumping in the air but again
we don't know the names of these
different transitions
so we're going to define a lathe act
latent action
z as being something that caused one of
these transitions to occur
but again we don't actually know that
these are the names of those different
transitions
um and so this can refer to
um or correspond to the real kinds of
actions that the agent can take in the
world such as moving to the right or
jumping in the air
um but it also might model some other
transition that's not necessarily
modeled by our action space
um such as bumping into the wall
so we're going to define a latent policy
as
being the probability that our
demonstrator
would take one of these latent actions
in this state here
um and so that that's what our latent
policy is going to be
um and so the way that we're going to to
learn that
is um so we introduced something called
the latent policy network
um so again i want to point out that oh
yeah sure
i just had a quick question which is do
you know the cardinality of the latent
um like the late number of actions does
someone tell you there's only 10 or
um is that also inferred yeah that's a
good question um
so it is it's it's a hyper parameter um
so we assume
like maybe we have the same number of
latent actions as
the actual underlying actions um in the
action space
but it turns out that it's sometimes
better to reduce the number of latents
or increase
um you know because sometimes the
demonstrator you know like if it's a
platform game the demonstrator will
never move to the left for example
or rarely move to the left and so we
might just say well just forget about
that latent action
um so yeah it's something that it's i
think it's a good start to
assume that it's the same number of
actions but it's definitely something
that can be tweaked um yeah
um and so okay so let's see how we can
actually learn this latent policy
um so we introduce this latent policy
network and what we're going to try to
do is
in each state we're going to try to
predict each possible
next state that can occur um given
one of these latent actions so we're
going to predict for example moving to
the right
jumping into the air um and i should
point out that
these latent actions aren't being
learned um so these are just going to be
a fixed input into the network now while
we're learning this generative model
that again is trying to predict each
next state we're also going to learn a
policy that's going to say
what is the probability that our
demonstrator took one of these latent
actions in each of these states
okay so let's go into more details about
how we actually learned that
um so let's say we've sampled a state
and next states
from our demonstration set which again
doesn't have doesn't consist of actions
and so again we're going to try to train
a generative model
to predict each possible next state
given
a latent action um and what we're going
to do
is we're going to find the predicted
next state that looks the most
like the next state that we observed
within our demonstration
and then we're going to try to minimize
the distance
between those two states
and the reason that we're going to try
to find the one that's closest to
um excuse me closest to the um observe
next state rather than
just penalizing all of them at the same
time is that this is going to free up
the generative model to try to learn
about each of the different kinds of
modes within
um the distribution so it's going to
allow it to basically try to predict
each
um possible next state um and basically
make each
transition as good as possible such that
if we observe that actual transition we
just minimize the distance between those
two things
um and so that's how we train our
generative model that's predicting next
states
um but the reason we have that um the
only reason we need that generative
model is because we need it to help us
learn our latent policy
um so now let's talk about how we
actually get this policy because that's
what we actually care about
um so again let's say that we've sampled
the state from our demonstration
set um so we might observe the following
distribution
from that state so let's say with
probability 0.5
our demonstrator moves to the right
jumps in the air with probability 0.5
and stays zero
stays still with probability zero
so if we wanted to compute the expected
next state under this distribution
you would get something that looked like
this and so
what we're going to try to do is we're
going to try to learn
our latent policy is going to try to
assign
probabilities to each of our next state
predictions
such as so that if we took the expected
next state under that distribution
it will look similar to the expected
next states
under our expert's distribution um and
so that's basically what we're going to
do we're going to be computing an
expectation
and so what we do is we just multiply
our
our next state predictions by the
probability of it occurring and then sum
up
um some over our latents here and then
we just
again we're going to minimize the
distance between
our observed next state and now this
expected next date
and this is how we're going to actually
be training our
um latent policy
okay are there any questions before i
move on because i know this is probably
a lot
okay um great so um
once we learn this latent policy uh
we're now
we basically need to figure out how can
we convert that over to actually real
actions
um so we basically just need to place
the agent within the environment
to again uh allow it to take a few steps
to align these latent actions
um with the real sorts of actions that
it can take in the world
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to introduce this action remapping
network
that's going to take in a state and one
of our latent actions and it's going to
basically say
absolutely induction likely corresponds
to this real action
in the world in the way that this is
going to work so now this is the online
step
um so before we are learning our latent
policy offline now we have to place the
agent online in order to
um do this alignment um and so what we
do is we
um have the agent taken action in the
states in order to get
um another the next state here uh
and what we're going to do is again
we're going to use our generative model
to predict each possible next state um
that can happen from that state
after taking one of these latent actions
we're going to again
find the prediction that looks the most
like the next state that we've just
observed
um and then what we can say is well that
laden action that i plugged into my
generative model
likely corresponds to the action that i
actually took that led me to that state
um and then so we can just do this sort
of relabeling here
and try to train this using something
like a cross entropy loss
so just to sort of summarize how control
is going to work
um so once we learn these things we can
place the agent within its environment
um it's going to excuse me i need
something real quick
um
it's going to select the latent action
um following the latent policy
and then it's going to um you know the
latent policy is going to point in the
incorrect direction probably because
it's been
labeled incorrectly um but then we can
plug it into
our relabeling function that's going to
say well you didn't mean move left you
actually meant
move right um and then we can just
follow
that relabeled policy that's basically
how
the algorithm works
uh so in our experiments we compare
against an approach known as behavioral
cloning from observation
and so this is an imitation from
observation approach that's
given a sequence of observations uh and
so what it's going to do is
it's going to try to um learn an inverse
dynamics model
so basically it's going to try to learn
this online so you place the agent
within the environment
and it's going to say given a state and
a next state
it's going to try to predict which
action was taken
then what it can do or what it does is
that it uses that label
to predict given a state in next state
coming from my demonstrations against
looking at the video
this is the most likely action that was
taken here
and then they can use that to say okay
well now i'm going to train a behavioral
cloning
policy given my state in this sort of
inverse
dynamics action that i'm predicting um
and so what it's going to try to do is
learn a policy using that
uh the problem with this um or i guess
one difficulty that you might have is
that
um it's going to be learning this
inverse dynamics model
at the same time that it's learning the
policy and it's having to collect
data um from that policy that it's
learning
um and so you can imagine that this can
be kind of difficult especially if you
have
um you know high divisional problems and
so
one of the benefits of our approach or
which we call ilco is that it learns our
this latent policy
offline so we already have an idea what
the policy is
we just have to figure out how to
correspond the latent actions to the
real
ones um so we don't have to learn a
full-blown policy online
and so we ran this in a few different
environments the first
the first environments were these
classic control problems so we have
a mountain car where you're trying or
the agent needs to balance this mountain
car
or sorry this cart pull um so yeah
in cartwheel you're balancing a pull um
in acrobat you're trying to swing this
thing arm thing up to the top and then
in mountain car you're trying to swing
back and forth in order to get to the
top of the mountain
um and so i should point out that all of
the states in this environment
are represented through vectors um and
so
these experiments are just showing how
our approach does against behavioral
cloning from observation or bco
when you measure the amount of episodic
reward it gets per
environment interaction and our approach
is shown
in purple and bcl is shown in blue
and so you can see here that we're able
to perform better than vco
and these approaches um basically we're
able to
learn with fewer environment
interactions because again we're
learning this latent policy offline
and so after just 50 steps of the agent
interacting with this environment i was
able to
learn how to balance this pull here um
and swing this acrobat to the top
although i won't make you
sit here and watch that happen um just
trust me on it
um and then we also run this in this
environment um called coin run
so again aquarium run the agent needs to
navigate to the end of the platform in
order to
obtain a coin and so now our states are
going to be represented through images
um so again you can imagine that it can
be a little bit more tricky to try to do
something like um
behavioral cloning from observation
because it's learning this inverse
dynamics model and
policy um at the same time whereas we're
going to learn the policy offline
um and so we ran this in a couple of
different instantiations of the game
one of one was when the coin was like
really close and then uh
another was when the coin was sort of
separated separated by this pit
um so it might be a little bit more
difficult for it to reach the coin
ashley um and this is the ship there's a
question
sorry to interrupt um from ali who asked
are the environmental interactions and
learning curves
just for the action remapping portion or
also for the offline
learning um yeah that's a good question
um so this is just
for the um action remapping portion
um so when it's interacting online uh
so yeah they're they're i would say that
there's definitely a trade-off um
so our approach
requires a lot of um data in order to
actually learn these latent policies
um but that data is offline um so
we basically assume we're more okay with
having
um having the demonstrator have to give
us a little bit more data than we are
with the
agent having to interact with the
environment
um but yeah there's definitely like a
bit of a balance between those two
things
and there's a second thanks and there's
a second question from aaron saying um
uh regarding illpo do you see any
obvious way forward to learn the number
of latent actions in a non-parametric
profession maybe with things like stick
breaking neural network models or stuff
like that
yeah that's a good question um so
we haven't worked with uh with trying to
learn the number of ladens
other than like trying to tune in our
hyper parameters
um there is a very similar paper that
came out like at the same time almost um
called learning
learning what to do before you do it i
think this is
out of berkeley and they do something
similar um i don't remember
if they're also assuming that the number
of lanes is a hyper parameter but
it's another i guess approach to take a
look into if you're curious about
um maybe that's sadly if we learned it
or not i'm not actually sure um but we
haven't we haven't looked into it
um yeah uh so when we compared or
actually
are there any other questions before i
move on
okay um yeah so we compared um again
against behavior playing from
observation
um in these uh coin run
uh tasks and you can see again that
we're able to perform better
um than behavioral coding from
observation if you're measuring
the uh reward that you get per
environment interaction
uh and so finally what i just want to
say is that um sometimes we can get a
little bit lucky when we're doing the
relabeling
um and so uh after just zero
steps for example some of our latent
actions can be relabeled to the right
the correct actions um so you see here
the agent is actually able to sort of
move towards the goal um even though
it's never take
taken any steps within the environments
um you can see it's like kind of
confused about
how to jump but it sort of like gets in
the direction of where the goal is going
um and then after just 200 steps of
interacting with the environments
it was actually able to solve the task
because again we're going to be learning
a lot of what we need to learn about how
to act
from from the observations before the
agent takes any actions in the
environments
um so in conclusion what i've just shown
in this work is that um
leading policies can be learned directly
from observation and if we want to
train an agent to imitate um it's just
going to require a few steps of trying
to map our latent actions
to the real actions that you can take in
the world um and if you're interested in
this work our code is available
online um so one thing
that we didn't consider is um
so we assume that our demonstrations
were coming from somebody
who knew what they were doing um so now
what i want to consider is
what's going to happen if our
demonstrations are actually suboptimal
um and and by suboptimal i mean actually
what if we're kind of terrible
um so if you're going to use
demonstrations such as this form
uh most typical imitation from
observation approaches
uh including illpo your agent would
typically do kind of terribly because
again they assume that you have an
expert that knows what they're doing
um and so what i want to discuss is that
we can actually learn
we can still learn from this sort of
data um using this new approach
that we've recently put out which is
estimating qss with deep deterministic
dynamics gradients or d3g
and so often if you wanted to learn an
optional
policy from sub-optimal data you can use
an off policy learner such as q-learning
where again you know you have your agent
and you're trying to
learn a policy that maximizes your
long-term expected return
um which is being represented by your q
values
but if you want to use an approach like
this to
learn from observational data where we
don't have access to actions
um we need to you know figure out how we
can reformulate our q
function um and so what we do in this
work is that we actually
say well now we're going to represent
our q values as
being the long-term expected return for
moving
to a neighboring state that's going to
maximize our qss values
um and so this is how we represent our
value function
and now instead of having a policy pie
we're going to have this model towel
that's going to say
in a given state can you propose which
next state i should move to
that's going to maximize my long-term
expected return
um and then so in order to figure out
which action i should take we're also
going to learn an inverse dynamics model
that's going to say um given a state and
my proposed next state tell me which
action will get me there
um but the benefit of this part where
we're going to be learning qss values
is that it doesn't require access to
actions and so we can learn it
completely offline
um in an off policy manner
from observation alone but before i get
to that i think it would be useful to
actually talk about the online scenario
where our agent is actually going to be
taking actions and interacting with its
environment
um and i i think this is just going to
be useful so that we can get
a little bit more familiar with some of
the properties of qss
okay so just to make it a little bit
more clear
the main differences between qss and qsa
is that qsa is going to be trying to
learn the reward plus a discounted
future return
or selecting an action that maximizes
our qsa values
where as we're going to be selecting
this next state that maximizes our
qss values
and then the way that control is going
to work is that
given a states we're going to now select
the state with the largest value
um coming and this is going to be coming
from our
model tel whereas typically you would
select the action
and that gives you the largest qsa value
um
and then we plug that into our inverse
dynamics model which is going to say
here's
um the action that would allow that
transition to occur
and then you can just follow that action
here um
so now let's talk about how we can
actually learn our qss values
um and so for now i'm going to consider
the tabular setting where
our qss values are going to be
represented by a table
um and so let's say um
so what we're going to try to learn is
um again our reward plus our discounted
future return for moving to our
neighboring state
that maximizes our qss values and
this can be learned in a similar way
that we would learn on our qsa values
using q-learning where now we're going
to set our target as being again our
reward plus discounted future return for
you know maximizing your qss values um
rather than having a max over your
actions here
um and we just want to basically try to
iteratively update this qss value so
that it looks more and more
like that target
um and so the way we represent tau is as
the
um so what we're going to try to do is
we're going to say select the state that
maximizes my qss values
um and then again we're going to have an
inverse dynamics model that says
given my state in this proposed state
coming from tau which action would
allow that transition to occur
um okay so uh
one thing i'd like to point out is that
um indeterministic settings um so i want
to be clear that this
this setup only works in deterministic
settings and we talk
more about that in the paper um but in
deterministic settings qss and qsa
values actually are equivalent so
we'll learn the same values um and so
what this heat map is showing is just to
learn values within a grid world
where an agent needs to navigate to a
goal here and you can see here that the
value
values learned by qsa and qss are indeed
very similar okay
so i just talked about how we can learn
qss in the tabular setting
um but if we want to get to you know
more difficult problems where our states
are continuous or
our actions are continuous we might not
necessarily have access to
this neighbor function and that's going
to say here are all the neighbors
um in from a given state um
and so and even if we had that it might
be intractable to try to maximize over
all of these different states
um and also so before we assume we had
access to this inverse dynamics model
but it could be
i think it's more useful to actually
have to learn this because
again it'll be difficult to actually
have that um function given to you
um and so what i want to show is that we
can
get rid of this max over the next states
um or this explicit max over the next
states um
and so if you think about how tau is
being represented
what we want is a function that's going
to
propose states that maximize our qss
values and that's that's what tau
is and so if you look at these um our
formulation for qss
it needs these states that maximize over
um
our qss values and so instead of having
this explicit max
um we can just plug in tau and get rid
of the max
anytime we see that sort of formulation
um so that happens here
as well so we can get rid of our max and
plug in
the tau and um so if you're familiar
with the work uh deep deterministic
policy gradients or
ddpg this is doing a similar sort of
trick
whereas you would um you would often see
like a policy being used here
and to avoid having to maximize over
actions um so now we're just going to be
using
tau to avoid maximizing over our states
so now let's talk about how we can learn
this um bargain we're interested in more
difficult problems
where we can't just use a table um so
now we're interested in using something
like a neural network
um and so here basically
our loss is going to be um or our target
is going to be our reward plus our
discounted future return for again
moving to a state that maximizes our qss
values
where now we're going to be plugging in
our cal function here and we just try to
minimize the distance between
our current prediction of qss and miss
target and again this is
similar to the ddp ddpg
trick and now so in order to learn tau
um so again we don't want to actually
have to iterate over this neighbor
function
um but basically we need tau to make
next state proposals that maximize the
qss values
and so we can just have a loss on the
negative q of s
and our proposed state coming from
tau um and because you know we're trying
to
or we have a negative on this um tao is
going to try to
predict states that maximize qss because
we're going to be minimizing this
function here
and then finally in order to learn our
inverse dynamics model
we can just put a supervised loss on
our inverse dynamics predictions and the
actual um
action that we observe from the
environment interactions because again
right now i'm talking about
um the online setting where we can
actually get access to this data
um and so uh i'll talk about in a bit
how we actually
can remove that assumption okay
um so one thing i should point out is
that actually uh
when we first tried out that loss our
approach did kind of terribly
so you can see here that the values were
actually being vastly overestimated
um and if you look at the trajectory
being predicted um
so this is just showing a grid world um
our tile function was predicting states
that were well
outside of the grid range um this is
sort of a common problem with
um gdpg style approaches or
reinforcement learning where
you know your values are going to be
often
overestimated and our model is learning
to exploit that bias
um and so what basically what we had to
do was find a way to
regularize our model so that it would
make reasonable
reasonable predictions rather than these
predictions that just sort of tries to
exploit the qss function
uh and so the way that we do this is
we're going to introduce the sort of
cycle loss um so it's there's a lot
going on here but i'll try to break it
down a bit
um so what we're going to do is we're
going to plug our state into our model
tau
to get a next state prediction
then we're going to plug that next state
prediction along with our current state
into our inverse dynamics model in order
to get an action
and then we plug that action as well as
our state
into a forward dynamics model in order
to
get another next state prediction and
what we can try to do is regularize our
model to be more consistent with the
actual dynamics within the environment
and so we can just have a loss on our
next state's prediction coming from our
model tau
and the next state prediction coming
from our four dynamics
um and so we can just append that loss
to our previous loss that we were using
for trading tau
um we also found it useful i should also
point out this that the c function here
um is just describing this whole process
here where we're
going to be getting out this four
dynamics um states
um but yeah we found it was useful to
actually plug that function
in anywhere that we saw this um towel so
that happens here
um and it also happens when we're
training the um
we're competing with target for learning
qss values
so that happens here as well uh and then
so once we
once we updated our loss with that sort
of regularization our approach did much
better
um and so this is just showing the
learned values um
and and now they're no longer being
overestimated
um and the neighbors that were being
predicted by our um
the model tell were no longer being um
being placed outside of the grid and as
training went on you actually see that
the predictions become
more and more grid-like which exactly i
mean that's exactly what you want but i
also think i think it's kind of exciting
because
this model is never getting any actions
um it's only
being trained to um basically try to
maximize its qss values and so now it's
actually being
able to make these sort of next state
predictions
okay um and so i also want to point out
that this approach can be used for
solving control tasks um so it's not
only useful for
um learning from observation we we
talked about
um again in the paper like a few
different um benefits to it
um so we ran it in these um control
tasks uh so this is known as majoko
um it's a sort of common benchmark use i
mean enforcement learning these days
um and so this is just showing that
we're able to perform as well as um the
state-of-the-art in several
of these different tasks although not
all of them um but i still think it's
like an exciting result
because uh you know we've introduced
this sort of new way of formulating um q
values
as well as coming up with a policy um
and i also think it's exciting because
we can use it for learning from
observation which is the point of the
talk
um so let's get back to that um so now
let's just consider how can we transform
this
sort of online learning setup i've just
discussed
into an offline learning from
observation scenario
where we don't have access to actions
okay and so that's the idea behind g3g
from observation
um where we're going to be given a
sequence of observations as well as
rewards
um and the reason that rewards is is
italicized is that
imitation from observation or even
imitation learning approaches often
don't assume access to the reward
function um
but in order to learn um an optimal
policy we assume this
um access to this and so i think of this
more as like um
like a batch or offline reinforcement
learning approach except
um and now we're doing it without
actions um
so yeah given that data we can learn qss
as well as our model tau
and then once we learn that then we're
still going to have the agent take some
steps within the environment to try to
learn the inverse dynamics
but the benefit of this part the first
step is that our qss values
can be learned completely offline um
and so the main fix that we need to do
so we can still again we can we
can compute all of our different losses
just from the data
offline um and the main thing that's
going to be taken out
um is the interactive step and so
here you're just saying this is just an
offline um
batch reinforcement learning uh setup
where we don't have access to actions
basically
okay so one problem um that we have is
that we still need to regularize our
model tell you know it doesn't it's not
gonna magically work again
now that we're doing this offline um but
the problem is that before we needed
access to actions in order to regularize
the model
um but really the only reason that we
needed the actions was that we could so
that we could plug it into
a four dynamics model in order to
predict the net states
um and so what we just need to figure
out is is
there's something that we can plug into
our forward dynamics model
but still going to allow us to predict
the next state um
and it turned out that we could actually
use our qss values here which is
kind of surprising um because we're
learning our qss values at the same time
and you know they're they're not an
actual
action um but it turns out it can sort
of act as
a a bit of a unique identifier that's
going to allow us to
um predict the next state from a given
state
um and this turned out to work well in
practice even though it seems a little
bit surprising
um and so what this is showing here is
just um
some random roll outs uh from inverted
pendulum and reacher and these are again
um so again if you're going to
try to train any typical imitation from
observation approach
using this sort of data um it would
often do kind of
terribly because it you know you assume
that you have like really good
demonstrations but what this is showing
here is actually that
our model tile is able to given those
random
rollouts it's able to predict solving
the task
even though it's never seen an optimal
trajectory um so you can see here that
it's predicting balancing the pull
um in predicting reaching um this target
here
uh and i should point out that these
trajectories were before the agent ever
had
any interactions with the environment so
this is just the
plans being generated by our model tau
um
after learning offline um
and so we also wanted to see um how well
did it do once you place it within the
environment
um how much reward was it able to
achieve uh and so
we basically obtained expert
demonstrations
or expert policies and we injected some
noise into them so that's what you're
seeing here
this is when we ejected no noise and
this is when it was 100
um random and we compare it again
against behavioral coding from
observation
um so you can see that when when our
policy was actually completely random
um our approach was able to perform
better than behavioral coding from
observation
as well as the expert and you can also
see
an inverted pendulum it was able to
achieve the highest possible reward
in this scenario we also
see that when there's no randomness
injected into the policy our approach
actually does worse
than behavioral coding from observation
um as well as a policy
but i think this is probably because you
know we're learning these things offline
and we need like a good variety of data
in order for it to actually be able to
learn meaningful dynamics and value
functions
but i still think it's exciting that
it's able to learn from completely
random data and finally we just
so what this is showing is just how well
does this compare against trading from
scratch
um so what we see here is the average
episodic reward um per time step
and we compare it against um again some
of the uh
the state-of-the-art and um one of the
state of the arts in continuous control
um so this is td 3 and dd pg um
and so i mean you would hope that you
know learning from officer a learning
from observation approach would
perform better than learning from
scratch um but what i just want to show
is that we're actually
able to as we get uh more and more um
random data we're able to actually learn
to
perform better um than td 3 and
gdpg um so this is just telling us that
it is actually learning something
meaningful offline from the observations
um even though it's never um it wasn't
given access to the actions
okay um so what i've just shown is that
um
our new value function qss um
and we introduced this predictive model
d3g that allows us to maximize these
values um
and i've shown that this allows the
nation to learn rather than only imitate
from observation
and again our code is available for this
work as well if you're interested in it
um and and now i just want to conclude
with considering
um you know if these sorts of approaches
can also be
useful outside of the you know typical
imitation or learning from observation
scenario that we might think of
um and so one scenario i think it could
be useful for is something like
agent to agent transfer so you can
imagine if you have one agent that has a
similar embodiment as another but maybe
somewhat different dynamics um maybe you
can learn something like a qss value
or use some other learning from
observation approach to learn
a value function and then relearn the
dynamics
function but still utilize that value
function in this new environment that
you're trying to transfer
over to um which might be a little bit
more tricky if you're trying to transfer
to
um in environments using a qsa value
because
you know your action space might be a
little bit different um
so the qsa value might not necessarily
transfer over
um another thing i think this could be
useful for is something like uh sim to
real
um so in central real you're going to
train your agent in simulation
um and transfer it over to the real
world um and so again you can imagine
like well maybe
in simulation my dynamics um or
the dynamics of a similar simulator
might be incorrect
um but it may be once we transfer it
into the real world
we can still maybe transfer over our qss
values and just
relearn our dynamics function
uh and finally i think it could be
useful to use like learning or imitation
from observation in multi-agent settings
where you wouldn't necessarily have
access to
the actions of these other agents but
maybe you can infer things like policies
or values of the other agents and and
allow that to inform your own policies
um so yeah i just want to also conclude
with saying um
you know this work wasn't done alone it
took place um
at uber and i and georgia tech with a
lot of different people so i just want
to give them a shout out here
um and yeah that's all i have so thank
you all for your attention
um i guess i probably have time for
questions as well
it's always so weird to give talks in
these formats um
let me uh ask one of the questions from
the audience that was super interesting
um one person on that said brainstorm
research are you assuming a single
expert providing observations and would
have been observations from multiple
experts be useful
yeah that's a good question um i mean
yeah and so in this work our expert is
actually just
we train a really good policy using
reinforced learning and then
use that as our expert so we don't
actually get like real demonstrations
from um
real people uh i think it definitely
could be
useful i mean you often have multiple
people giving these sorts of
demonstrations
um i don't know if it would make any or
it would
well actually i think it could be
helpful because it will give us a good
variety of data
like if somebody um you know always does
the same sort of actions
maybe you know another demonstrator will
give us different kinds of action so we
we can get to see these different sorts
of transitions that we wouldn't
necessarily see if um
if we had a single person doing the same
thing over and over again
awesome and i got a question so um in
the spirit of sort of
um some of the focus of a lot of the
focus we'll be talking about this fall
is going to be theory and so i was
curious
um are there any hardness results that
compare learning from
observation to learning from settings
where you also get the actions
good question to be honest i have no
idea i haven't i haven't seen anything
um i don't know i think it seems like an
interesting question i know that like i
think it was stefan ross or no maybe
someone drew back nelson i think when
son had a little bit of work comparing
imitation learning well you do get the
actions to rise
but i don't think i've seen anything for
the pure observational setting
yeah that's a good question yeah i think
there is a paper on like
provably efficient imitation from
observation i think um
from like firing boots and i think also
the author that you mentioned maybe
there's like my papers on it but
it's not really my area another question
from aaron
um i and they wanted to check um
they say that if you were to consider
the stochastic setting
learning queue of ss prime would likely
be heavily entangled by dynamics in that
setting
is that something you said all the work
that you were doing there assumes
deterministic settings have you guys
done extensions or thought about the
stochastic setting yeah
yeah that's a good question um so
we did run experiments for ilpro with
this actually both ill pro and qss with
stochastic um so
i guess the problem with um
ilpo is that it sort of assumes that um
your dynamics are like the same thing as
a policy
um because you know you're saying like
if i end up in this next state then
that's because the policy said it and
not because dynamics sort of
put me there um and so i think in order
to get around that sort of problem you
would need to
utilize environment interactions and to
try to figure out how to disentangle the
policy from
um from the uh
environment dynamics and without that
our the approach
it still kind of works um but it doesn't
do like as well
um so i mean that's definitely something
that's sort of ingrained in the um
formulation um qss isn't it
so it has a different sort of problem
whereas um it's coming up from that max
over next state
um so it's assuming that it's going to
land in the next state
that's optimal um and again if you if
you have stochasticity then you're not
going to
um necessarily land in that next state
that's optimal
whereas if you're if you're taking your
qsa values that sort of stochasticity is
built into the formulation
of qsa because it doesn't assume what
states you end up in basically
um so i think that the main difference
is that
your qsa formulation is taking in your
state and the action that you
took whereas um
qss is taking into account the states
and the state that you
that you end up in but i think it would
be more useful to say
this is the state i was trying to reach
so if i have like
given my states and this is the state
that i wanted to end up in
and then you just plug that into your
qss formulation
then i think it could probably take into
account some of the stochasticity of the
environments because sometimes you
wouldn't end up in that state and you
would get a different reward
um so it's something that we've looked
into we haven't actually had
many experiments with it yet um i
definitely think it'll be useful to try
to get that to work though
that's super cool thanks
yeah are there any other questions
i think there are a few on q a let me
see um so one person said it
ali said really amazing work so
fascinating by the results and how it
remembers bacharael um
uh and he's just really excited to see
it trying out one more other question
which is whether
from the same um from ali whether you've
tried to use the lanes for transfer yet
um and how well this sort of latent
policies learned in one environment
might transfer to another
environment because anything that's sort
of not already done in coin run um but
it'd be interesting to see in other
games
and i apologize in advance
unfortunately at 4 30 but um trouble was
here for longer questions as well and
thank you so much for the talk
yeah no problem thank you so much again
it's been a fun
fun experience experience um
yeah uh so let me think so so we haven't
tried transfer learning
um within um the latents
uh so we haven't we haven't done any
transfer loading for that
we do have experiments um within our
d3g approach for um or actually you know
qss approach
um where we try to transfer to an
environment
with um uh slightly different
actions um i mean it was a very simple
environment so basically we wanted to
transfer from one grid rail to the other
um they both had similar actions but
they've been relabeled differently
um and so you can imagine like if you
have a grid world where up is
represented by zero and then you
transfer it to an environment where up
is
represented by one or something like
that um
you know so qsa wouldn't necessarily
work very easily with that but qss
is just sort of like part of the
formulation of it that it can handle
that
um we haven't really tried it in more
difficult problems though
um i do think it's it's going to be
interesting there's definitely going to
be
um some uh challenges because
uh so qss sort of assumes um
you know like you're going to given a
say end up in the same next state and so
if you want to transfer it over to
another
environment you might not necessarily
reach that exact same
next state um you know you can imagine
like one agent moves faster than the
other
slower or whatever um and so i think
that you're
in order to get that to work on qss
values as well as how we're learning
how to go from one state to the other um
so rather than using like an inverse
dynamics model we might need to use
something like a goal condition policy
that says
this is how you get from this state to
the next state um
but yeah this isn't isn't something that
we've tried yet but it's definitely
something that we've thought about
okay i started to speak uh yeah
very cool uh very nice work uh i believe
emily
meanwhile had to leave uh
yeah no problem so i'm i'm checking
whether there are any more
questions um
by the way we do have a discord uh
server
uh you know this chat sir right uh
do you mind uh checking out whether
people want to ask questions later there
because people you know like
might go through the talk uh we could
post your slides there
and uh have some questions uh
i can give you access to it yeah that
sounds good yeah
yeah yeah i have access i'll post my
slides and i can answer questions on
there as well
okay awesome um thank you so much
yeah thank you as well yeah it's been
fun
all right take care youtube bye-bye
thanks bye
you